this video is very very very important
so I would take notes I'm gonna try to
make it really really simple but it's a
very important concept you may have
watch other videos with parts of this
information but I wanted to create one
video just to explain everything okay so
what we're talking about is how to
prevent someone from going from a
pre-diabetic state to a diabetic state
now the difference between pre-diabetes
and diabetes has to do with your blood
Sugar's so in pre-diabetes your blood
sugars are around 100 to 125 diabetes
it's 126 and greater we're talking about
another test called a1c which is an
average of three months of your blood
Sugar's we're dealing with a 5.7 to a
6.4 with pre-diabetes and then once
you're diabetic becomes 6.5 or greater
so really when we're talking about
diabetes type 2 we're just talking about
the elevation of sugar in your blood a
normal blood sugar should be about 80
okay
and what that means is you have about a
teaspoon of sugar in all of your blood
okay so it's not that much and you don't
need to consume a teaspoon of sugar to
get that your body will make its own
sugar out of fat out of other types of
calories okay
so that's what pre-diabetes is that's
what diabetes is now what happens is
this an average person consumes about 31
teaspoons of sugar every single day and
I'm talking about the other
carbohydrates that can turn into sugar
as well it's not all just teaspoons of
sugar so they're consuming a lot of
carbs roughly could be around I don't
know 300 grams or even more for the
average American
so that's crazy amounts of sugar now
look at this a normal blood sugar is
only one teaspoon of sugar over here
we've got 31 teaspoons so why is it when
someone consumes a lot of sugar
the average American why isn't the blood
sugar just screaming high all over the
place
usually it's normal at least for a
period of time well that is because we
have this filter right in the middle of
this thing and it has to do with this
machine that keeps the sugar out of the
blood and it's called insulin so insulin
kind of filters out and gets rid of the
excess amount of sugar in the blood and
what does it do with it it hides it
it'll put it in stored sugar called
glycogen in the liver and the muscles it
will also put excess in the fat it will
convert some to cholesterol but the
thing that the body doesn't want is high
amounts of sugar in the blood why
because that sugar is very very
dangerous to the lining of the arteries
it will start to corrode and it's called
oxidation or damage inside the arteries
and then comes the plaquing and the
calcium and that whole thing so your
body really considers excess sugar very
very dangerous if this person is
consuming a lot of carbohydrates and has
a high frequency of eating having a lot
of snacks what happens is you're gonna
get a huge amount of insulin being
released from the pancreas and that
insulin is working really really hard to
keep the sugar down but here's the other
thing high levels of insulin is also
very toxic to the body as well so your
body doesn't like high amounts of sugar
or high months of insulin so what does
it do it starts to reduce the insulin by
creating a resistance okay it's called
insulin resistance so the cells start
blocking insulin like crazy the problem
is the body still has to keep this under
control so it starts to turn up the dial
and produce more and more insulin to
penetrate through this resistance to
keep the sugar at a normal level and
this whole game continues for a period
of 10 to 15 years so you may have
instant resistance for 10 to 15 years
until all the sudden this pancreas says
you know what it's been compensating
it's been working
hard to kind of counter this problem to
help you but now it's exhausted so the
pancreas can no longer pump out that
much insulin so this starts going down
and down now we don't have as much
insulin well guess what's gonna happen
if you keep consuming this amount of
carb at this frequency this sugar is
gonna start to go up why because our
insulin is going down so the sugar is
gonna start going up over time it's
gonna then turn into full-blown diabetes
now understanding this problem is so
important if you are a pre-diabetic or
even you have insulin resistance because
it's so easy to solve with just a little
bit of effort you can avoid this whole
thing and it really has to do with
cutting out the carbs and going on in a
minute fasting now the other thing that
I want to tell you is very very
interesting the doctors are focused on
the blood sugars only they're not
measuring your fasting insulin level
they're not measuring if you have
insulin resistance the test that you
would do to determine that B Homa IR
okay but that's never done so this area
is kind of hidden this is the area that
you see this happens later in life this
happens way before 90% of people that
are pre-diabetics don't even know their
pre-diabetics they just wake up one day
and they're a diabetic now I would say
probably 99% of the people don't know
they have insulin resistance now I'm
going to tell you right now the symptoms
to determine if you have insulin
resistance even without taking this test
okay
all you have to do right now is just
look down and see if you see your belly
if you see your belly and you can't see
your your feet that we know you have
insulin resistance here are some other
symptoms
frequent urination even at night are you
getting up to the night in urinating
this is
you have if you were just to change your
diet you would notice this symptom
improving within a few days brain fog
memory problems because your brain is
dependent on this glucose and when you
have resistance guess what you starve
the neurons with its fuel and you start
becoming forgetful to start of dementia
but when you cut out the carbs you'll be
running your body on ketones and you can
bypass that whole thing and feed your
brain and you'll actually have a lot
more focus and less memory problems but
here's the big symptom right here to
know that you have instant resistance
you cannot go a long period of time
without getting hungry you need a snack
between meals you need a snack at night
this is probably the big one craving for
carbs is a big one or chips or some type
of cracker especially at night is a big
symptom tired after eating you want to
take a nap after your lunchtime we know
you have instant resistance tingling in
the feet or burning in the feet or any
type of sensation in the hands of the
feet is right in this area right here it
could be this area too that means that
your blood sugars are destroying the
vascular system the capillaries to the
nerves in your feet that's called
peripheral neuropathy very very very
very simple to fix all you do is you get
off the high carb diet stop eating so
frequent I put some links down below of
how to do this and just so you know
sugar is very oxidative and it creates a
lot of inflammation and the inflammation
actually even makes this worse
it actually can push you from here to
here just having the inflammation also
omega-6 fatty acids like in all the
different oils soy oil corn oil
cottonseed canola oil those are very
highly inflammatory that can also push
you over the edge as well as msg like
monosodium glutamate it's in a lot of
fast food restaurants anyway I gave you
a lot information I hope you now have a
deeper
standing of really how simple this
concept is thanks for watching hey with
another amazing recipe no brains no
sugar
totally Kido there's no suffering
Nikita absolutely not Karen and it's an
immune system builder absolutely you
have to check this out I think you
should hurry up watch the recipe and
make it yourself it's just so easy to be
Kido
but is it simple it's super simple we
hope you enjoy making it as much as we
are enjoying audience